Is it okay to take different brands of supplements other than the ones you tested?
It's okay. You could do whatever you want, but when I test this supplement, sometimes the brand is important.
So I know there's other brands out there that can be far less expensive.
There's a lot of influencers out there that push their own brands and they private label things just like we do.
Unfortunately, there's a lot of them that private label real cheap, sorry, but crappy supplements because
they can get them so much cheaper and then they can make a whole lot more money off them because
they honestly just don't care about. It's just volume. They don't have you as a patient. They just
have you as a supplement customer purchaser. So they don't care about you personally. They just want to
sell supplements. And I'm not judging everybody's personality, but you have to understand there's been
studies done where independent companies have taken different brands of supplements and tested them for
actually the truth in labeling. And it's it's it's unbelievable. Some have zero, you know,
of the accommodation that's listed of, you know, 500 milligrams of accommodation, it had zero in there
was all just rice ground rice flour. So you do have to be careful with different supplements and just
because it has some influencers name on it does not mean it's a good quality supplement. So
just just know that you you do have to be careful. And when I test you on different things I'm
testing you on the supplement that I'm testing you on. So you are taking not saying it's a big risk.
I'm just saying it's a risk. So you're going with a with an off brand supplement even if it's a big
influencer's name of the brand.